can you file a lawsuit in the form of a  comic book  well the answer is apparently yes in a  case  in texas in a suit between a comic book  store and  a hotel next door there was a third  amended complaint so  the plaintiff apparently filed some  motion saying that they needed more  clarification  and in response to that the plaintiffs  got really cheeky and they filed their  complaint  effectively as a comic book halfway  through the complaint it basically just  switches to an  illustrated comic and they explain all  of the events that  involve basically a bunch of patrons in  the hotel throwing large metal canisters  off the hotel and into the comic book  store in the form of a comic book will  this work that remains to be seen but it  is  hilarious and incredibly interesting  i've never seen this one before so we'll  see this comic book  in court